[Music]
hallo you took just lost my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
19th episode of my chest trap series in
this episode I'm going to show you a
wonderful high profile trap in the
Queens gambit accepted line from the
white perspective
now the qga arises after the following
model d 4 d phi c 4 and now except the
pawn with d capture c4 ok the main line
continues with the move Knight to f3 so
stopping any fi idea by black and black
concentrate on his piece development
with Knight to f6 okay III serve I try
to regain the point with Bishop capture
c4 and it is in the device for the black
to hang on to the extra pawn because
then a 4 and B 3 comes in a flash and
the resulting position is quite good for
the white so that's why here the main
line continued with the move ecigs and
after Bishop captures c4 black can
continue with either of the option he
can immediately play c5 or let's say in
this game black plays a6 first and after
White Castle now black plays the move
safe I so this is pretty much the
starting position of the main line of
Queens gambit accepted now by far the
most popular choice over here is a 4 by
wide widths permanently stopped the beef
eye but as usual I'm going to show you a
very surprising line and in this video
I'm going to recommend this move that is
Quint we - at first sight it doesn't
make any sense because it free of cost
give black this important tempo beef I
and grab every single space on the Queen
side but as we move on you will
understand the big point behind it once
again here the most popular choice is
Bishop b3 but I'm not going to recommend
that instead of that I propose this
tricky move Bishop to d3
and the trap is set right here now as
per the database here there are mainly
two popular choices by the black and
those are sea captains d4 and Bishop to
b7 in this video we are going to
concentrate on the move Bishop to b7 but
I have included a sample line sea
captain's d4 we're wide obtain a
slightly advantageous position push up
to b7 and black is completely busted in
fact he has fallen into of a trap and it
is so amazing that this is the most
popular choice by black and there are
more than 160 games in database played
from this position where I feel very
sorry for the games who has been drawn
or the lost by the white pieces here by
accurate play white immediately get the
winning edge of a trap start with the mu
d capture c5 so you can see here there
are mainly two choices by the black and
neither of them give any solution to the
black side the first more I want to
consider which is Bishop kept a c5 which
looks more natural as it regained the
pawn develop a piece and ready to castle
on the King side so what can be wrong in
this case well here is the answer
boom hahaha so suddenly from nowhere
white get a full pawn advantage if any
piece comes in between then white can
take that piece or even retrieve the
bishop back and in that case what will
be a clear pawn up so question arise
what happens if black accept this piece
ecla files well after that I think it's
very simple
yep Queen captures B file checking the
king in same times hitting two piece and
black and not defend both the piece so a
simple line can roll like this
Bishop to c6
win capture see file and now yes indeed
Black has this move that is Bishop
captures f3 and after G captures f3 my
King safety is somewhat compromised but
in return white get two pawns and those
are the distant past on the Queen side
so with accurate play this indeed of
winning position for the white the
second most popular choice in this
position is Knight to c6 which stop this
sort of nasty ideas but here what has
this wonderful move before consolidating
his extra pawn and asking black Hey
what you are going to do next if black
doesn't capture the pawn then white is a
clear pawn up with a very good advantage
so the obvious question need to be arise
what happens if your opponent plays
Knight captures before well here the
same trick happen yup you guessed it
Bishop captures b5 ah black has to go
choices if he played Knight to c6 back
then the simplest is you take this night
and after Bishop takes you just continue
harassing black pcs with a knight to
deform hitting the bishop and it doesn't
matter whether black protect the bishop
or move somewhere let's say Bishop to
defy but there comes Bishop to e3
protecting his extra pawn and once again
getting a very good advantageous
position so Knight to c6 is not a good
solution in this position more critical
is a captures b5 and after Queen
captures B Phi yes indeed black is going
to lose his piece but black has this
tricky move in the picture Knight to d7
now surprisingly enough in the database
all the game here continued with the
Queen captures before but I don't like
this line the simple reason is after
Bishop captures f3g captures f3 yes
indeed white one upon but his King
safety is severely compromised so
instead of this my recommendation here
is you go for this wonderful attacking
and forcing line Queen captures b7 rook
to b8 then Queen to e4 is a very strong
reply and I think the reason why white
doesn't choose this line because he is
afraid of Knight - see - and this is the
most critical response in this position
but here white can easily give up an
exchange but in return he get a
tremendous activity let me demonstrate
this by showing you one of my rapid game
in this position where against our 2,200
rated opponent I continue with the move
rook to d1 it doesn't matter whether
black plays Queen to see it or Knight
captures even in this game black plays
Knight captures even but after rook to
d7 attacking the Queen kindly note Queen
cannot capture the Brooke because his
own ruk hanks with a check so in the
game black has to forcefully play Queen
to CH and here it looks very tempting to
play rook captures f7 but it technically
doesn't work and let me show you how if
white goes for this then after Queen
captures b7 rook captures b7 and now the
star mu castle on the Queen side by
force white lose the whole rook
that's why instead of route capture sep
7 in this position the better movies
night B to D 2 and after this our
threads are very much potent there are
two good moves in this position rook to
b8 then Queen to c7 is a very strong
reply and other move which is played in
this game that is Bishop captures c5
but after this by force white gets the
winning advantage with Bishop to b2
black decide to save his night but after
Bishop captures d7 rook to g8 Bishop to
f6 so there is a threat of rook to d8
and if he can't the material at this
point White has a knight and a to pawn
for a miserable passive rook which I
personally think is a great advantage
for the white ok the forcing line
continue here with Queen captures b7
rook captures b7 here black cannot play
the move rook captures a 2 as after rook
to b8 the devastation happens on the
back rank and surprisingly enough
engines suggest that black has to give
up a piece with Knight captures III but
even after that the resulting position
is quite superior for the white I think
my opponent was time trouble in this
position and he was struggling to find a
better move as he continued with the
move Bishop to b6 which at first sight
stopping the move looked to be aid and
threatening the a2 but as it turned out
that this is a big time blunder as after
Knight to e4 attacking the bishop bishop
to f8 and now Knight to e5 and there is
no way black and save this game the game
finished very quickly
he played Knight - before I continue
with Knight captures f7 and after Knight
to d5 which threatens the f6 Bishop but
what my opponent completely missed is
there is a forcing mate in this position
before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out a sequence where
you checkmate the black ink
okay are you ready let's start night
check Bishop captures d6 Knight captures
d6 AK King to f8 is the only reply and
after rook to f7 a sweet goodnight kiss
to the black ink well I hope you enjoy
and learn this wonderful high profile
trap in the Queens gambit accepted thank
you for watching this video feel free to
write subscribe and comment on my video
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care